j'ai joué quatre ans un mec sur scène
qu'en rase un autre mec est un premier
calcul niveau roulage coppel ma femme
est en deuxième position
depuis 2014 majid berhila n'est plus
ryan des lascars gays
pendant trois ans le duo qu'il formait
avec hugues duquesne participants on
n'demande qu'à en rire
l'émission ur de laurent wauquiez majid
berhila joue maintenant seul sur scène
j'avais envie à un moment donné d'être
moi sur scène j'ai envie de m'exprimer
correctement sujet vers des compléments
ne pas avoir cet accent de banlieue et
j'avais envie de me dévoiler je pense
qu'à un moment donné c'était bien de
repartir sur autre chose j'avais envie
d'être moi tout simplement
ses inspirations son enfance en picardie
l'arrivée de ses parents du maroc sa
célébrité issus de l'émission
majid berhila veut casser les clichés le
tout avec dérision autres artistes ce
soir là les jumeaux eux aussi issus de
l'émission leur force une folie douce
qui parle de tout et de rien et place
d'un coup on vous a vidé la piscine
[Musique]
oui surprendre à chaque fois on s'est
dit que à chaque fois que les jugements
arrive on sait pas ce qu'ils vont faire
est ce que cette délimitation de la
parodie est ce qu'on est en costard
comme on est sur scène ce qu'on va faire
du stand up des sketches on sea dit que
pourquoi les limites c'est ce que se
focaliser se cloisonner si on peut faire
beaucoup de choses
leur vie les inspirent mais aussi la
politique
un univers mouvant qui les oblige à
modifier sans cesse lorsque j'entends je
suis très content des tricheurs à mon
aîné le premier jeu réussit un petit peu
pour me détendre un petit peu pour me
consoler d'une certaine façon parce que
vous le savez et à manger
j'ai été éliminés du premier tour en
plus des des primaires aimé vais
défoncer
[Musique]